...
-Cela prend exactement 38 secondes
pour voir tout Paris.
C'est le temps dont
a besoin l'ascenseur
pour atteindre le 59e étage
de la Tour Montparnasse.
La métropole gît aux pieds
de la plus haute maison de Paris
à une hauteur de 209 mètres.
Elle s'étale jusqu'à l'horizon,
un océan de maisons
qui n'en finit plus,
la destination rêvée pour
les touristes, sensée être la ville
de l'amour, de l'aventure,
du romantisme et des lumières.
Paris, la ville des miracles.
Quand on voit le Sacré-Coeur,
cette basilique blanche
sur la colline de Montmartre,
on y croît facilement
au miracle de Paris.
Celui qui se sent perdu,
reconnaîtra la coupole dorée
du dôme des Invalides.
Le voilà.
Le célèbre Arc de Triomphe.
Et évidemment,
la Tour Eiffel.
On la connaissait depuis longtemps,
bien avant qu'on vienne la 1re fois.
Et chacun a déjà entendu parler
de la Place de la Concorde.
Voilà, mais maintenant les faits.
La capitale française s'étend
sur 105 km2.
Plus de 2 millions de personnes
vivent dans ses murs.
Si on y rajoute ceux
qui habitent aux alentours,
on arrive à presque 10 millions de
personnes avec la grande banlieue.
Le molosse Paris se divise
en 20 arrondissements.
Chaque conscription est constituée
de quatre quartiers parisiens.
Le véritable centre,
c'est l'île de da Cité,
une île sur la Seine,
l'origine de Paris.
Sur cette île se dresse un
des plus grands monuments parisiens,
la cathédrale de Notre-Dame.
Il y a plus de 100 musées à Paris.
Au musée d'Histoire
on peut observer
l'évolution de la ville.
Les Parisii, un peuple de chasseurs,
de pêcheurs et de marins
se sont installés environ 250 ans
avant Jésus-Christ
sur l'île de la Cité.
A cette époque,
l'île s'appelait Lutetia,
un nom que les Parisiens ont repris
des anciens habitants celtiques
qui peuplaient l'île auparavant.
Les conquérants romains
appelaient l'endroit Lutèce
et ils la grandirent,
au-delà de l'île
à droite et à gauche du fleuve
en l'an 51 avant Jésus-Christ.
Lutèce fut une colonie romaine
pendant 300 ans.
La ville prit le nom de Paris
au IVe siècle après Jésus-Christ.
L'île sur le fleuve, sur laquelle
l'histoire de la ville commence,
ne fut pas pour Paris
uniquement importante
de part de sa position géographique.
Les Parisiens et les Romains
se réfugièrent sur l'île de la Cité
lorsqu'ils furent attaqués
par les Huns et les Francs.
On dit que les prières ardentes
de Sainte Geneviève
empêchèrent Attila
de détruire la ville
et c'est ainsi qu'elle est devenue
la patronnesse de Paris.
Le roi franc Clovis s'installa sur
l'île en 500 avant Jésus-Christ
et fît de Paris la capitale.
L'île de la Cité, tel un vaisseau,
a toujours subie
les remous du temps,
un vaisseau qui décore
les armoiries de la ville.
Leur divise est typique :
Fluctuat nec mergitur.
Il flotte mais ne coule pas.
On peut admirer l'île de la Seine
sur de nombreuses cartes postales
ainsi que son monument
le plus connu, Notre-Dame.
Il n'y a aucune vue
de la cathédrale
qui n'ait déjà été admirée
dans les endroits
les plus reculés du monde.
Pour les touristes, la visite
du Dôme de Paris est un must
et est souvent le commencement
de toutes les visites guidées.
La cathédrale.
Son nom officiel,
Notre-Dame de Paris.
Elle a aussi des surnoms :
la paroisse historique,
l'église-mère de la nation
ou le temple
de l'histoire de France.
Ce chef-d'oeuvre gothique,
avec ces clochers de 69 m de haut,
est construit là où les celtes
rendaient des sacrifices aux dieux
sur un temple.
La construction de Notre-Dame
commença au milieu du XIIe siècle
et fût achevée 200 ans plus tard.
On entre dans l'église
par trois portails.
Au milieu, le portail
du Jugement Dernier.
Notre-Dame est
le centre de la France.
Devant le portail
c'est le point zéro,
à partir duquel toutes les rues
du pays vont être calculées.
On dit que celui
qui fouille du pied
ce point zéro y revient.
Les particularités architecturales
de cette basilique à 5 vaisseaux
et transepts
feraient l'objet d'un film en soi.
C'est pourquoi nous décrirons ici
l'esprit de ce sanctuaire national.
Avec ses nombreuses chapelles,
ses audacieuses poutrelles en ogive,
ses merveilleuses rosaces.
On voit ici pour la première fois
des particularités architecturales
qui seront dominantes
dans l'architecture française
jusqu'au XIXe siècle.
Le mariage de la monumentalité
et de l'élégance,
l'équilibre des proportions,
associés à une mise en forme
d'harmonie presque classique.
Même la Révolution
n'y peut rien changer,
elle qui fît de la maison de Dieu
un temple de la raison
après avoir volé ses trésors
et détruit ses statues.
Plus tard,
elle fût un entrepôt de vin
mais Notre-Dame survécu.
Les nombreux visiteurs
qui chaque jour se pressent
jusqu'à sa plateforme
n'y sentent que peu
l'esprit de l'Histoire.
Plus personne ne craint aujourd'hui
la vue de ces chimères de pierre.
On tremble le souvenir
du sonneur de Notre-Dame
Victor Hugo qui immortalisa
le célèbre sonneur Quasimodo
et la tzigane Esmeralda
a dépeint
la signification de Notre-Dame
et de l'île de la Cité
très justement dans son roman.
Près de la cathédrale
se dresse l'une des plus importantes
constructions de l'île.
Le Palais de Justice.
Des centaines d'années durant
le centre du pouvoir.
Les celtes Parisii
y résidaient déjà
dans de simples habitations.
Puis les Romains et les Francs
avant que les rois français
y construisent le palais.
Plus tard, les prisonniers
y furent conduits par les tribunaux
et emmenés sur des charrettes
à grandes roues à la guillotine.
Parmi ces prisonniers,
la reine Marie-Antoinette
et le révolutionnaire Robespierre.
Aujourd'hui ce bâtiment porte
un nom qui décrit bien sa fonction,
le Palais de Justice.
Pratiquement encastré
dans les dédales
du Palais de Justice,
a survécu un chef-d'oeuvre gothique
de grande qualité :
la Sainte-Chapelle,
considérée comme l'une des plus
belles constructions parisiennes.
La Sainte-Chapelle se compose
de deux chapelles.
L'inférieure, lieu de recueil
pour les courtisans et le peuple
et la supérieure,
avec ses vitraux incomparables
qui était uniquement réservée
à la famille royale.
Les fenêtres d'une hauteur
de 15 mètres,
ont été construites en même temps
que l'église
entre 1245 et 1248.
Ce sont les plus vieilles
fenêtres de Paris.
Les murs luminescents ne semblent
pas respecter les lois de la gravité
car la construction n'est portée
que par de fines poutrelles.
Plus de 1100 scènes, dont
la moitié encore sont d'origine,
nous relatent des récits bibliques.
Il paraît qu'on gardera
encore de nos jours
dans la chapelle du château
les restes de la couronne
d'épines du Christ
et des instruments
du martyre de Jésus.
La Sainte Chapelle sortit intacte
de l'incendie du Fort Royale
au XVIIe siècle.
L'île de la Cité, coeur de Paris,
ne serait présentée
qu'insuffisamment
si l'on ne parlait pas des ponts
avec lesquelles l'urbanisme
moderne a commencé.
Le Pont Neuf.
Aujourd'hui, comme lors
de sa construction
sous Henri IV, en 1605,
il protège les exclus sociaux
et sert de point de rendez-vous
aux amoureux.
Une promenade
pour ceux qui veulent
jeter un regard
de ce côté de la Seine
du haut de ce monument.
On l'appelle le Pont Neuf,
car ce fut le premier pont
sur lequel
on ne construit pas de maisons.
La vue imprenable
sur l'île de la Cité
en fît le pont
le plus aimé de Paris.
Et voici à quoi rassemblaient
les autres ponts à l'époque.
Des maisons à étage occupent
chaque centimètre carré d'espace.
La densité n'empêche pas
les citoyens
de s'amuser à des jeux en bateau.
Le Pont Neuf.
Une partie d'une des paysages
urbaines les plus célèbres du monde,
chanté par Jacques Verrières
et Nathalie Guéraud.
-A Paris.
Quand un amour fleurit,
ça fait pendant des semaines,
2 coeurs qui se sourient,
tout ça parce qu'ils
s'aiment à Paris.
Au printemps,
sur les toits, les girouettes
tournent et font les coquettes
avec le premier vent
qui passe indifférent,
nonchalant.
Car le vent,
quand il vient à Paris,
n'a plus qu'un seul souci,
c'est d'aller musarder
dans tous les beaux quartiers
de Paris.
Le soleil,
qui est son vieux copain
est aussi de la fête
et comme deux collégiens,
ils s'en vont en goguette
dans Paris.
Et la main dans la main,
ils vont sans se presser,
regardant en chemin
si Paris a changé.
-A changé.
Et les autres,
ceux qui en ont assez
parce qu'ils en ont vu de trop
et qui veulent oublier,
alors ils se jettent à l'eau.
Mais la Seine...
Elle préfère
voir les jolis bateaux
se promener sur elle,
et au fil de son eau,
jouer aux caravelles
sur la Seine.
-Les ennuis,
y en a pas qu'à Paris,
y en a dans le monde entier.
Oui, mais dans le monde entier,
y a pas partout Paris.
Voilà l'ennui !
A Paris,
au 14 juillet,
à la lueur des lampions,
on danse sans arrêt
au son de l'accordéon,
dans les rues.
-DEPUIS QU'A PARIS,
ON A PRIS LA BASTILLE,
DANS TOUS LES FAUBOURGS
ET A CHAQUE CARREFOUR,
IL Y A DES GARS
ET IL Y A DES FILLES...
-Qui sur les pavés,
sans arrêt, nuit et jours...
-FONT DES TOURS, ET DES TOURS,
A PARIS.
-Oui, la Seine.
On dit que ses quais réunissent
les amoureux du monde entier.
Cependant,
la ville est séparée en deux.
La rive gauche, qui depuis
la construction de l'université
et du monastère
est considérée comme la rive
des intellectuels un peu bohèmes
et comme celle des révoltes.
En 1968, les manifestations
étudiantes commencèrent
à Place Saint-Michel, là où se
trouve la fontaine Saint-Michel,
construite en 1860 par Davioud
et décorée par les sculptures
de Duret.
On peut commencer sa découverte
de Paris par ici
quand on est nouvel arrivant.
Dans les rues
et les ruelles pittoresques sur
lesquelles planent depuis longtemps
une odeur de pizza et de couscous.
On se sauve vite vers
les quais de la Seine,
vers les stands des bouquinistes.
Auparavant, les étudiants
y achetaient leurs livres,
leurs bouquins,
de là vient le nom.
Aujourd'hui, on trouve surtout
des amateurs de vieux graphiques,
de plans historiques
et de livres d'antiquité
qui veulent faire des affaires.
Au quartier latin,
le quartier des étudiants,
il y a la plus grande
université française,
la Sorbonne.
En 1254, Robert de Sorbon
fondait un collège
qui fut repris environ 400 ans plus
tard par le cardinal Richelieu.
Depuis 1821, on trouve
dans les gigantesques complexes
les directions universitaires.
Dans ce quartier animé,
il y a aussi des places de calme
comme la place Fürstenberg.
Le peintre Delacroix avait déjà
admiré sa beauté.
C'est là que
se trouvait son atelier.
Delacroix,
un des grands hommes français.
Les plus grands d'entre eux
sont enterrés au Panthéon,
un mausolée national qui était,
à l'origine, une église.
Ils sont tous réunis là :
Voltaire, Rousseau, Victor Hugo,
Zola et plus de 50 autres
personnalités encore.
Près du Panthéon, dans le jardin
du Luxembourg, un parc baroque,
ne se repose pas que
d'étudiants.
Le parc a reçu son nom
du château du Luxembourg
construit de 1615 à 1631
La retraite de veuvage
de Marie de Médicis,
aujourd'hui siège
du Sénat français.
Les familles, les amoureux
se retrouvent ici,
surtout le week-end,
ainsi que les capitaines
des grandes villes
avec leurs bateaux miniatures.
...
Nous considérons aujourd'hui
que les boulevards de quartier
sont typiques de Paris.
On y fait du shopping.
Les cafés, les bistrots et
les stands sont alignés côté à côte.
Mais personne ne pense
qu'au temps de Napoléon III,
son préfet, le baron Haussman,
restructura radicalement la ville.
On rasa 20 000 maisons,
on a reconstruit 40 000.
Les rues, droites, étaient bonnes
pour les défilés militaires
mais elles détruirent
les constructions de jadis.
Mais la vie parisienne se manifeste
encore sur les boulevards.
"Laissez-faire, laissez-aller".
Même à l'ombre de l'église
de Saint-Germain-des-Prés.
On ne sent pas le pouls
de la grande ville,
dans les petites rues
derrière l'église.
Des vieilles boutiques,
des petits cafés
au bord de la rue,
des légumes, du poisson,
sans l'odeur du fast-food
et du couscous.
Voici la Rue Debussy
avec des petites rues adjacentes,
une idylle et qui le reste.
Le quartier latin,
le boulevard Saint-Germain,
le boulevard Saint-Michel...
Des endroits et des noms
qui rendent aussi un peu triste.
Où sont-ils passé les chansonniers
et les poètes, les bohémiens ?
La technique
les remplace aujourd'hui.
...
La rive gauche n'est pas seulement
un lieu pour les visiteurs
à la recherche du temps perdu
au quartier latin.
Là où les trains partaient
et arrivaient de province,
à la gare d'Orsay,
se trouve aujourd'hui
un musée renommé où est rassemblé
la plus grande collection
de tableaux impressionnistes.
La gare fût construite en 1900
en face du Louvre
comme pièce décorative
pour l'Exposition Universelle.
La gare qui, malgré
son apparence élégante,
devait être rasée
dans les années 60.
Une des inaugurations
des musées les plus réussis
eut lieu entre 1978 et 1986.
L'architecte Aulenti créa un cadre
exceptionnel pour les collections,
surtout pour les collections
de peintres français d'Art déco
et les impressionnistes.
Mais les sculptures,
ici une de Rodin,
ont aussi rendu
le Musée d'Orsay célèbre.
Cette sculpture,
une petite danseuse de 14 ans,
est de Edgar Degas,
un des rares impressionnistes
qui travailla aussi
en tant que sculpteur.
Le peintre Degas est devenu célèbre
avec ses tableaux
aériens de danseuses,
un thème qu'il représenta souvent.
Les Coquelicots à Argenteuil,
de Monet,
est un chef-d'oeuvre
impressionniste.
De même, Le Déjeuner sur l'herbe,
d'Édouard Manet,
tableau qui fit scandale
au Salon de 1863.
Elle devint le manifeste
d'un groupe de peintres
qui cherchaient à fixer
l'instant et la lumière
dans leurs tableaux.
Du nom "impressionniste",
attribué ironiquement,
ils firent un programme.
Van Gogh est aussi un des plus
grands artistes du XIXe siècle.
Voilà son autoportrait
qu'il a peint
dans une maison de santé.
Qui ne s'arrêtera pas
devant un Gauguin
pour voir la magie polynésienne
avec les yeux de l'artiste ?
Auguste Renoir a représenté
dans Le Bal du moulin de La Galette
la joie de vivre
du peuple parisien.
L'ambiance de Montmartre
en peinture.
Voir Renoir, mais aussi Sisley,
Toulouse-Lautrec, Cézanne
et bien d'autres encore.
Tout cela rend un séjour à Paris
si précieux.
De plus, se trouve à rive gauche
un monument assez particulier,
celui qui, dit-on, est le plus beau
monument religieux de France
qui a été construit
depuis la Renaissance,
le Dôme des Invalides.
Sous la coupole
de 105 m de haut
repose le Français
le plus célèbre,
et peut-être même le plus
représentatif : Napoléon.
Le Dôme des Invalides prit
sa forme actuelle au XVIIe siècle
sous Louis XIV.
Une maison pour soldats
retraités ou malades
était déjà en place en 1604.
Le cercueil de Napoléon,
cercueil de quartzite rouge,
repose sur un socle de granite vert.
Le petit Corse qui monta en grade
de simple lieutenant,
au poste de général,
qui fut premier consul, puis 1er
Empereur de tous les Français,
a refaçonné l'image de la France
et de l'Europe toute entière.
Lorsqu'il mourut en 1821
dans son exil de Sainte-Hélène,
le monde avait radicalement changé.
Même sa ville, Paris,
avait un nouveau visage.
L'école militaire, par contre,
avait déjà était instituée
par Louis XIV.
Le bâtiment d'époque classique,
une école militaire pour officiers,
a été construit sous l'initiative
de la maîtresse du roi,
Madame de Pompadour.
Elle éleva ainsi un monument
à la gloire de ses protecteurs.
En face de l'école militaire,
vers la Seine,
se trouve le champ d'exercices,
qui porte aussi le nom
du Dieu de la guerre, Mars.
Le Champs de Mars,
aujourd'hui transformé en parc,
relie l'école militaire
et la Tour Eiffel.
Avant de nous consacrer à la
construction de fer de M. Eiffel,
regardons,
de l'autre côté de la Seine.
Exactement dans l'axe
de l'école militaire,
on trouve la Tour Eiffel,
le Palais de Chaillot
avec ses musées.
A l'avant de la Place du Trocadéro,
très visitée par les touristes,
on a une vue d'ensemble
imprenable.
Gustave Eiffel a crée la véritable
image de marque de Paris
avec sa construction de fer
de 300 m de haut.
L'esthétique technique de
cette oeuvre, réalisée en 1889
pour l'Exposition Universelle,
a trouvé de son temps
plus d'opposants que de partisans.
A cette époque, on préférait
le parc des expositions,
un grand hangar
de verre et de fer où on
accédait en passant par la porte
de la Tour Eiffel.
Ce hangar n'existe plus
depuis longtemps.
A sa place, on a aménagé
le Champ de Mars.
La Tour Eiffel, elle, a survécu.
Et avec elle
la plus belle vue de Paris.
...
Tournons-nous maintenant
vers l'autre Paris,
le Paris bourgeois,
les quartiers royaux,
le Paris du gouvernement,
le Louvre, les Champs Elysées,
mais aussi Montmartre.
En un mot, la rive droite.
La rive droite
et ses arrondissements.
Mais, par où commencer ?
Par la tour Saint-Jacques,
peut-être.
Ce clocher se dresse
juste derrière l'île de la Cité.
L'église fut rasée en 1802.
Les chimères et les figures saintes
ne peuvent pas faire concurrence
avec celles de la cathédrale
mais protègent, pour ainsi dire,
la Place du Châtelet.
Jusqu'à la Révolution, il y avait
ici une forteresse d'où on
contrôlait les ponts qui menaient
jusqu'à l'île de la Cité.
Ici se trouvent aussi 2 grands
théâtres parisiens, face à face,
construits par Davioud
que nous avons déjà mentionné
comme architecte
de la fontaine Saint-Michel.
...
À quelques pas de là,
le parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville.
La ville y est administrée
depuis 1356.
La construction médiévale fut
remplacée par un palais renaissance
dans le style
des châteaux de la Loire.
C'est dans ce bureau
que le maire de Paris
décide du destin de la ville.
Si l'on prend part
aux réceptions officielles,
on peut se laisser impressionner
par l'intérieur pompeux
de l'Hôtel de Ville.
Jusqu'en 1830,
les exécutions publiques
se faisaient sur ce parvis.
Le mot "hôtel" se retrouve aussi
dans l'expression
"hôtel particulier",
un terme utilisé pour dénommer les
palaces de la noblesse parisienne.
On en trouve beaucoup
dans le quartier du Marais,
entre l'Hôtel de Ville
et la Bastille.
Beaucoup de ces hôtels
particuliers sont restaurés.
Quelques hôtels-musées, comme
l'hôtel Carnavalet, qui est aussi
le Musée de Paris.
Ces hôtels ont presque tous
une cour intérieure
avec un jardin privatif
séparé de la rue
par de hautes murailles.
Le Vieux Palais a été construit
par l'architecte François Mansart
au XVIIe siècle.
Dans les 80 salles,
on peut y visiter une exposition
sur l'histoire de Paris
avec des peintures, des sculptures
et des reliques des siècles passés.
Une place d'honneur est réservée
à la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen,
document datant de 1789.
Un an plus tard, on fête
pour la 1re fois le 14 juillet
en commémoration
de la prise de la Bastille.
Charles Thévenin
a immortalisé l'instant
dans une fresque magistrale.
Des citoyens et des soldats
s'y embrassent.
On peut reconstruire l'histoire
de Paris à travers ses tableaux.
Une leçon d'histoire
par excellence.
Au faite, l'Hôtel Carnavalet
était un lieu de rencontre
pour intellectuels qui entretenaient
des causeries mondaines.
C'est ainsi que la très fine
Madame de Sévigné
qui participa activement à une
critique de l'actualité mondaine,
nous offrit sa vision de Paris.
L'Hôtel Salé construit
avec l'argent des impôts
prélevés sur le commerce du sel,
a aussi été restauré, et accueille
dans ses murs
la plus grande collection d'oeuvres
de Pablo Picasso,
ce génie incontesté du XXe siècle.
Ici encore, on retrouve
la même disposition architecturale,
celle d'un petit château,
telle qu'elle fût en vogue
jusqu'au XVIIIe siècle.
Après plusieurs séjours
dans la capitale,
Picasso s'installa à Paris
en 1904.
Voilà un autoportrait,
datant de 1901.
Voilà comment il se voyait
lors de son arrivée à Montmartre.
Et voilà comment le photographe
le voyait au même instant.
L'atelier de Picasso
était toujours rempli d'amis
et de collègues peintres.
Voici la Russe Olga Khokhlova,
sa troisième muse,
une oeuvre de 1917.
Après sa période cubiste,
Picasso retourna
à la peinture figurative.
Et voici encore un portrait d'Olga.
On voit bien la progression
qu'a suivi l'artiste
jusqu'en 1929,
époque où il a peint ce tableau.
À l'Hôtel Salé, on peut suivre
toutes les époques
stylistiques de Picasso.
Ce portrait vient
de la période bleue,
il fut encore peint à Barcelone.
Les Deux Frères, de 1906,
de la période rose,
puis les influences du cubisme,
le Sacré Coeur.
Paul habillé en Arlequin,
de 1924.
Plus tard, Picasso
a peint néo-classique
pour s'adonner de plus en plus
à ses productions expressives
et déformantes.
Au musée, on peut voir aussi
ses sculptures originales.
Paris a toujours été
une ville de contrastes.
Des hôtels particuliers à côté
de petites maisons bourgeoises.
Haussmann a changé la ville
de façon radicale,
contre l'air du temps.
Aujourd'hui encore, on critique
les nouvelles constructions.
Par exemple, le Centre Pompidou.
Les architectes Richard Rogers
et Renzo Piano ont laissé courir
tous les tuyaux d'alimentation
à l'extérieur de l'édifice.
Certains disent que Beaubourg
ressemble plus à une usine
qu'à un musée.
D'autres considèrent
que c'est une expression
contemporaine idéale.
En tout cas, Paris a encore montré
ce que voulait dire "innover".
Et presque 10 millions de touristes
par an lui en rendent hommage.
Les collections d'art
et les expositions itinérantes
y sont aujourd'hui acceptées.
La fontaine Stravinsky
de Niki de Saint Phalle
et de Jean Tinguely
a presque l'air anodine.
Ici, tous les touristes
veulent appuyer sur le bouton.
Aujourd'hui, les loyers grimpent
considérablement dans ce quartier,
mais c'était
un quartier pauvre et à assainir,
selon les urbanistes.
Le ventre de Paris.
C'est là que les marchands
avaient leur mot à dire.
Dans le café Au Pied de Cochon,
qui se trouvait en face des Halles,
on pouvait manger la meilleure
soupe à l'oignon de la ville
24 heures sur 24.
Les Halles étaient,
comme la Tour Eiffel,
typiquement parisiennes.
La forme ronde des Halles
est restée,
symboliquement.
Quand les Halles devinrent trop
petites pour l'énorme marché
du centre-ville, on le déplaça
en banlieue parisienne.
L'art et l'urbanisme moderne
ont refoulé tout un peuple
bigarré de marchands, de bonnes,
de souteneurs, de clochards
et bien d'autres encore,
devant l'Eglise Saint-Eustache.
Le quartier "malfamé"
devient un quartier chic.
Le forum des Halles
fait aussi partie
du ventre de Paris.
Un énorme centre commercial
surgit de nulle part.
300 000 personnes
s'y ruchent chaque jour.
On y trouve restaurants, cinémas,
discothèques, cafés et manèges.
Les façades des rares maisons
que la grande restructuration
a épargnées se reflètent
dans les bâtiments de verre.
Le nouvel Opéra de Paris,
Place de La Bastille,
est moderne et bien dans
l'esprit du siècle.
Au centre du sens giratoire,
le Génie de la Victoire,
appelée la Colonne de Juillet,
en Allemagne.
Elle a été construite
à la mémoire
des victimes de
la Révolution de Juillet.
...
C'est l'endroit où se trouvait,
jusqu'en 1789, la Bastille,
une prison lugubre et terrible
et qui le resta jusqu'au jour
où le peuple a assailli la Bastille,
transformée en bastion
de défense des forces de Paris,
un 14 juillet,
aujourd'hui fête nationale.
Le symbole de l'oppression.
Tout commença au matin
du 14 juillet 1789,
quand les citoyens de Paris
s'emparèrent des armes
au Dôme des Invalides
et marchèrent sur la Bastille.
Ils attaquèrent comme
un seul homme. Rapidement,
les soldats de la Bastille
hissèrent le drapeau blanc.
Quelques jours plus tard,
les murs du bâtiment détesté
furent détruits.
La prise de la Bastille
marqua le début
de la Révolution française.
Le roi et la reine
furent destitués.
On voit ici le roi Louis XVI
et Marie-Antoinette
se faire leur adieu en prison,
en larmes,
surveillés par le gardien
de prison Rochet.
Louis XVI est mort
le 21 janvier 1793,
Place de la Concorde,
guillotiné.
La même année, en octobre,
Marie-Antoinette subit
le même sort.
Les temps changèrent,
même pour le palais royale.
Le palais du Louvre
qui aujourd'hui abrite
une institution démocratique,
le Conseil d'Etat.
Le Louvre, le château
des rois de France.
On ne peut vraiment
apprécier sa dimension
que dans une perspective aérienne.
Le Louvre n'a pas toujours
eu l'apparence qu'il a aujourd'hui.
L'histoire de sa construction
commence au XIIe siècle
et elle est très complexe.
On y trouve la plus grande
collection d'oeuvres d'art du monde
qui recouvrent les périodes
artistiques occidentales,
de l'Antiquité à nos jours.
Voici la Vénus de Milo,
un modèle pour bien
des sculpteurs de l'Antiquité.
La section égyptienne est renommée.
Elle est présentée
sur plusieurs des 200 salles.
Les larges galeries du Louvre
sont réservées à la peinture.
Les objets d'art du Moyen Âge
et de la Renaissance
sont incontournables.
Compter le nombre d'oeuvres
majeures qui sont ici exposées ?
Impossible.
Même si la Mona Lisa,
de Leonard de Vinci,
ne doit pas manquer à l'appel.
Des peintres français, italiens,
flamands, espagnols et allemands
sont représentés.
Voici un célèbre
autoportrait de Dürer.
Et, évidemment,
Peter Paul Rubens,
un des porte-paroles
du style baroque.
L'Infante, de Velasquez.
Et chaque génération
est de nouveau fascinée
par le peintre hollandais
Rembrandt.
Les salles sont aussi pleines
de paysages de différentes époques.
Ici un paysage modèle
de Claude Lorrain.
Ici une vue de Venise
par Canaletto.
Les maîtres du classicisme
sont présents,
tels que l'Ingres
avec ses nus parfaits.
Eugène Delacroix éternisa
l'image nationale des Français
dans son tableau La Liberté
Conduite par le Peuple.
L'ancien côtoie le neuf,
même au Louvre.
On atteint la cour intérieure en
passant par une pyramide de verre.
Les critiques la décrivent
comme une serre
qui détruit l'harmonie
de la façade.
Ceux qui sont pour parlent
du monument le plus osé
et le plus beau de Paris.
Mais les contradictions
et les controverses
font partie de Paris,
tout comme la Pyramide du Louvre.
En face du Louvre,
après le petit Arc de Triomphe,
se trouve le Jardin des Tuileries,
la Place de la Concorde, avec
l'obélisque, puis l'Arc de Triomphe,
et la nouvelle arche
du quartier de la Défense.
Cela représente un axe
d'environ 10 km
à travers Paris.
Chaque fois qu'on cite sur cette
diagonale mérite d'être visité.
Le Jardin des Tuileries,
par exemple.
Le parc fut aménagé en 1664
et est un des parcs
les plus prisés de Paris,
avec ses allées rêveuses,
ses statues de Maillol,
ses bancs et ses kiosques.
...
A l'entrée du Jardin des Tuileries,
la Place de la Concorde,
toujours très animée.
C'est la plus grande
rotonde du monde qui fait
400 sur 200 m. C'est la plus
grande scène parisienne.
Mais les pièces qu'on joua ici
furent variées,
comme le nom même de la place.
A l'origine, à la gloire du roi,
la place devait offrir
un cadre digne de recevoir
une effigie du roi à cheval.
Puis, pendant les 13 mois
de la Révolution, on guillotina
ici plus de 2 500 têtes.
Enfin, on y dressa l'obélisque,
un cadeau d'Egypte au roi
citoyen Louis-Phillipe.
Au fait, on trouve aussi ici
le Jeu de Paume, un musée qui
auparavant qui exposait les tableaux
des impressionnistes. Aujourd'hui,
c'est un musée d'art contemporain.
Napoléon rebaptisa
ce théâtre de plein air
en Place de la Concorde.
De nos jours, on y joue
la pièce Les Temps Modernes.
La Place de la Concorde
est un centre névralgique
de la circulation parisienne
et des flots de voitures
se pressent vers l'Arc de Triomphe.
Au nord de la place,
se trouve l'ancien Opéra de Paris,
le Palais Garnier,
le temple culturel
de la bourgeoisie parisienne,
le symbole du Second Empire,
tout à fait dans le style
de Napoléon III.
Un architecte jusque là inconnu,
Charles Garnier,
s'imposa contre une concurrence
de 170 projets.
La construction commença en 1862.
On prit en considération
les exigences pompeuses
de la classe dominante
et les besoins les plus modernes
du théâtre de l'époque.
Le fast atteint son sommet
dans les foyers dorés.
De nos jours, l'Opéra n'est plus
techniquement à la hauteur.
C'est pourquoi on a construit
la nouvel Opéra de la Bastille.
Ce bâtiment est maintenant
réservé au ballet.
Haussmann rasa tout un quartier
pour la construction de cette opéra.
Le boulevard du même nom,
derrière l'Opéra, le rappelle
à nos mémoires.
Sur ce boulevard,
se trouve le grand magasin
le plus célèbre de Paris,
les Galeries Lafayette.
Tous les désirs s'accomplirent
sous sa coupole magistrale.
Les parfums, le chic et les
accessoires de la vie parisienne.
Même sans rien dépenser,
on peut se régaler les yeux
et assister à la rénovation de
Notre-Dame à l'aube du XXe siècle.
Mais les habitués du grand magasin
se fournissent ici en plan gratuit,
offert par les Galeries Lafayette.
Mais beaucoup préfèrent payer.
Après tout, Paris
est la ville de la mode.
Les grands couturiers
dans les palais
se trouvent Rue de Rivoli
et Rue du Faubourg-Saint-Honoré
ne se gênent pas pour présenter
à intervalles réguliers
leurs collections dans ce magasin.
...
On reste dans le quartier
de la rive droite.
Nous avons escaladé la montagne
de Paris, Montmartre.
Enfin, juste une colline
mais qui semble dominer Paris.
D'un blanc éclatant
elle semble être couronnée
par la basilique du Sacré-Coeur.
Les architectes les plus renommés
ont refusé son style "bonbon".
On dit que
c'est un mélange improbable
du style romain, byzantin
et classique. Les touristes,
eux, sont emballés par sa beauté
et par son exposition exceptionnelle.
Les amateurs d'art refusent
de se mêler aux touristes
qui se pressent Place du Tertre.
Plutôt que de prendre des photos,
on s'y fait dessiner.
La petite place
est toujours très visitée.
Elle profite de la renommé
des artistes
qui avaient leurs ateliers
sur la butte de Paris.
Montmartre, jadis un chemin
qui était difficile à gravir.
Ce n'est pas étonnant que
les loyers étaient bon marché.
Qui avait-il ici, hormis l'église ?
Ce que les artistes trouvèrent
à l'époque abordable,
d'autres le trouvèrent chic.
Les cafés où l'on payait
avec ses tableaux
sont devenus des attrapes-nigauds.
Mais même de nos jours,
on ne peut échapper
à quelques pas de là
au charme bucolique
de cette colline.
Et même ici, on en vient
à parler du grand art.
Ceux qui sont à la recherche
d'oeuvres de Salvador Dali,
visiteront le Musée Espace Dali.
Oeuvres plastiques et graphiques
de cet espagnol excentrique
y sont représentées.
...
Et puis,
dans le cimetière Montmartre.
on y trouve encore la tombe
d'Emile Zola.
Ses ossements ont été emmenés
en 1908 dans la nécropole
où reposent les grands
hommes français au Panthéon.
D'autres personnalités
y reposent aussi :
Degas, le poète Heinrich Heine,
Stendhal, Sacha Guitry et Truffaut.
La nuit, tous les chats
sont gris, ici aussi.
Mais pas tous les chats
qui traînent à Montmartre,
comme entre
la Place Clichy et Pigalle
un quartier qui vit
de la Belle Epoque
mais qui, pourtant,
n'est qu'un piège à touristes.
Mais si l'on veut absolument
vivre le vice à Paris
et bien, voilà.
On en suit les traces ici,
mètre par mètre.
Pourtant, même ici
on devrait éviter de généraliser.
L'art du show-biz
et des dîners aux chandelles,
l'art des shows télévisés
et des prestations internationales
on le trouve aussi ici.
Le paradis latin.
En fait, ce n'est pas à Pigalle
et c'est tant mieux.
Les extraits du programme
entre chansons, revues et cancan.
...
Paris by night.
La nuit n'appartient pas
qu'aux revues.
Conduire de nuit sur les Champs
Elysées c'est une aventure nocturne.
Le spectacle permanent
qu'offre Paris,
s'offre à nos yeux
jour et nuit.
Les Champs Elysées
avec ses 10 voies
ne sont pas représentatifs
du bon temps.
Le bon temps c'était avant.
On l'appelait la Belle Epoque.
Cette fin de siècle offrit à Paris,
entre autres, un édifice
qui mit en scène l'axe Champs
Elysées, Dôme des Invalides
de manière efficace.
Le Grand Palais, construit en 1900
pour l'Exposition Universelle,
couronné d'un quadrige de bronze,
fait partie de cette mise en scène.
Le Grand Palais et
ses 5 000 m2 d'exposition
est un des plus grands
centres d'expositions de la ville.
Juste en face,
se trouve le Petit Palais.
On accueille ici
des collections parisiennes
et des expositions itinérantes.
Les deux bâtiments furent
construits en même temps.
Mais tandis que le Petit Palais
est encore d'un style baroque,
le Grand Palais cache
derrière sa façade
une structure de fer et de verre.
Les deux palais
et le pont Alexandre III
forment un ensemble.
Le pont, avec sa pierre de taille,
ses candélabres de bronze
et ses ferronneries,
surplombe la Seine dans un arc
d'une longueur de 100 mètres.
Nombreux sont ceux
qui pensent que ce joyau de
la Belle Epoque est
le plus beau pont de Paris.
C'est un témoignage de l'alliance
signée en 1892
entre la France
et l'Empire Russe tsariste.
Le tsar Nicolas II
et le président français
déposèrent ensemble
la première pierre.
Le président de la République
qui résidait,
comme tous ses successeurs,
à l'Elysée.
La relève de la garde du matin
s'effectue Rue Saint-Honoré.
Cette rue qui d'autre part
est synonyme de haute couture.
La République française
est démocratique.
Mais les présidents républicains
ont toujours su se dorer
au soleil du prestige
de la splendeur de Paris.
Et quand l'occasion se présente,
ils se montrent et se fêtent
aux Champs Élysées
que ce soit pendant des parades,
de jours fériés ou
des réceptions officielles.
Cette avenue magistrale
souvent appelée
la plus belle avenue du monde
n'était à la fin du XVIIIe siècle
qu'un chemin
pour sortir de la ville.
On trouve aujourd'hui à Paris des
rues bien plus belles qui ont été
modernisées et commercialisées.
Mais aucune
n'est aussi représentative,
aussi à cause de l'Arc de Triomphe.
Napoléon le fit construire
en l'honneur
de la Grande Armée française
après les victoires
de Marengo et d'Austerlitz.
Cet arc de 50 m de haut
et de 45 m de large,
qui avait été prévu
pour la Place de la Bastille,
fut terminé
sous Louis-Philippe en 1836.
La Marseillaise devint célèbre.
C'est une des quatre
grandes sculptures latérales.
Tout en haut de l'Arc de Triomphe,
se trouve un petit musée.
Mais on grimpe les marches
pour pouvoir apprécier d'en haut
une vue fantastique.
Douze grandes avenues partent
de l'arc en forme d'étoile.
Si l'on suit l'axe est-ouest
qui part du Louvre,
passe sur la Place de la Concorde
et l'Arc de Triomphe,
et qu'on aille plus à l'ouest,
on y discerne au loin
les quartiers de Nanterre
et de la Défense.
C'est là que s'est exprimé
le Paris du XXe siècle.
A partir de 1956, quand la guerre
d'Indochine fut terminée,
on assista
un développement économique
et un élargissement de la ville
dans la région parisienne.
La Défense fut construite
pour accueillir des bureaux
et des administrations.
L'arche s'y trouve depuis 1989
et est devenu le symbole
de ce quartier éprouvette
provoquant de nouveau
des controverses.
Elle nous montre sûrement
la route de l'avenir.
Au nord de la ville,
à la Porte de La Villette,
on a aussi mis
un accent futuriste, un Parc des
Sciences où on peut s'informer
sur la technologie de l'espace.
À la géode,
une boule d'argent énorme,
on peut voir des films en 3D.
Le moyen de transport le plus
rapide à Paris c'est le métro.
Pour le retour,
prenons notre temps,
et faisons donc
une promenade sur le canal,
de ce côté un peu moins
connu de Paris,
par le canal Saint-Martin,
avec ses vieilles écluses,
nous rentrons jusqu'au coeur
de la ville, la Bastille.
Ce voyage romantique
nous a conforté dans notre opinion.
A Paris, on peut toujours
découvrir quelque chose.
...